what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again
with a new attack on time video this
time we're gonna talk about the war
hammer
titan the last time to be revealed in
the anime i wanted to use the anime
introduction
as an excuse to talk about the warhammer
titan some more give my thoughts on it
and measure just how strong it is
compared to the other titan powers
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you can do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know let me know in
the comments if you want to see a
similar video for one of the other titan
shifters where i break down their own
strengths
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on time videos
before we get started i want to thank
raid shadow legends for sponsoring this
video
rage shadow legends is the epic
collection rpg game played by tens
of millions of people all over the world
use my links below to download raid
yourself on mobile phone or pc
while i tell you more raid has 13
different factions including orcs
dwarves high elves dark elves and many
more
if you scroll to the index screen you
can find them all
there each faction is made of many
unique champions
personally i love the high elves because
they have a fascinating society and
culture and also because let's be real
they have some top tier waifus last
month raid got their
biggest ever update the doom tower is
here
it's a giant tower with 120 floors a
bunch of secret challenge rooms
and 12 badass bosses to take on there's
never been a better time to start
playing and the raid team are giving
away a bunch of new free goodies plus a
special champion to help you get started
in the tower ball work
if you want to get a head start in raid
all you have to do is click the link in
the description and you'll get a free
void champion
an xp booster 50 gems some energy
refills and
even an ancient shard you will find your
extra rewards here
in your inbox for the next 30 days only
just click the link in the description
to get started now without further ado
let's jump into it the warhammer titan
was the ninth and final titan shifter
power to be revealed to us
it appeared right around chapter 100
chapter 101 to be specific but yeah that
was quite a nice reveal after 100
chapters of attack on
titan it turned out that the user of the
warhammer titan was willie tiber's
sister
the one that appears to be in a maid
outfit willy previously told maggeth
that he did
see the warhammer titan user when they
were passing through the tiber house
looking back in the manga the tiber
sister was positioned in the back right
perfectly blending into the background
as if she could be the family's maid
she transforms into the around 15 meter
tall warhammer titan after aaron's
attack titan interrupts willy's speech
aaron is quick to attack the warhammer
titan as soon as he sees it to the point
that he gets a punch off before the cool
medieval knight looking armor
has even materialized you gotta respect
that reaction speed
however interestingly enough this clear
initial advantage that he has
isn't enough for him to overpower the
warhammer titan his titan suddenly gets
impaled by a giant spike that
effortlessly lifts his giant body into
the air
by using titan hardening the warhammer
titan can create weapons or anything
else it needs from underground
in fact the tiber sister uses this
ability to create the warhammer titan
itself
while she hides in a titan crystal
underground one of those nearly
indestructible ones that annie created
around herself aaron later recalling his
fight against the warhammer would say
it was an annoying enemy aka a tricky
and tough opponent
it didn't have the vulnerability that
most titans have
namely the vulnerability of being stuck
in your titan's nape where people can
get to you
for the warhammer titan aaron destroyed
its upper body including where the nape
was
but it made no difference because the
tiber sister was underground safe in her
crystal
a brief note on this crystal we've seen
the tiber sister and annie use this
crystal to protect themselves
we don't know if all titan shifters can
learn how to use this power
if for some odd reason only female users
can use it or if it is a specific
ability of the warhammer titan and if
annie used her female titan's ability to
copy the abilities of other titans by
consuming parts of them to learn this
ability from the warhammer titan
perhaps marley set it up so that
warhammer titan parts were part of the
things that they made annie choke down
while they were experimenting with her
powers the fact is we don't know yet
but i thought it was worth mentioning
because the titan crystal could if the
latter theory is correct be a
specifically
warhammer ability and this ability to
create a titan crystal around yourself
especially the way the warhammer titan
uses it should not be underrated
in annie's case she's just in a crystal
and can't turn into her titan in that
form
while the warhammer because of its
unique abilities can stay in this
crystal while it creates
its titan and fights with it the only
known way to destroy this nearly
indestructible crystal is
through the jaw titan the jaw titan's
jaws and claws
are the only things that were able to
break through this crystal
so if porco galliard was never helped
out of that hole
and never joined the fight aaron could
not have taken the warhammer titan power
as he did
you could say the jaw titan is super
effective against the warhammer titan
it is the warhammer's kryptonite or
achilles heel but let's get back to the
fight against aaron at marley and
some of the truly crazy things that we
saw from the warhammer titan
obviously it could form a war hammer
using its hardening abilities and this
ability to form things from the ground
is very reminiscent of the way
emir fritz forms titan bodies or helps
regenerate titan shifters from the
unknown land
where she molds the special ground there
into whatever she's making
the war hammer titan is similarly
forming things from the ground only in
the quote-unquote real world it happens
instantly the best comparison i could
make
is if you watched avatar the last
airbender the warhammer titan
is a lot like a very skilled earthbender
the warhammer titan signature warhammer
is very long
maximizing striking distance and it also
has spikes on its end
rather than a flat surface to maximize
damage when aaron's titan dodges it
instead of making
one big spike like before the warhammer
titan makes countless smaller spikes
jet out of the ground if you pay really
close attention these spikes are made
with mini spikes on them facing the
opposite direction
so that when a titan gets its feet
caught on them it is very difficult to
get unstuck
thus aaron's titan is stuck in place and
can't escape the warhammer this time
he goes crazy hardening and reinforcing
his arms again and again to block the
hammer
but the hammer is so strong and sharp
that it not only breaks through his
heart and arms
but straight through his titan's head as
well with just
one swing just as the warhammer titan is
going to deliver the finishing blow
we find out that the tiber sister can
talk in her titan form and she asks
aaron if he has any final words although
she is not the first titan to talk since
zeke peak and amir all spoke in their
titan forms too it
is cool nonetheless this may be less of
a warhammer titan thing though
than an individual user thing since we
didn't see marcel
and porco speak even though they had the
same titan as amir of the survey core
anyways the only thing that saves aaron
here is mikasa showing up and
thunderspearing the warhammer titan
yet even though mikasa thinks the job is
done it's not
aaron destroyed the nape once then
mikasa did a second time but the
warhammer titan keeps regenerating
because it's users underground and not
in the name this is where things get
really crazy for me the warhammer titan
creates a crossbow
a weapon that needs to be flexible in
order to work
it's fascinating that the warhammer's
hardening can create a material
similar to the strength of a crossbow it
shoots the giant crossbow at
aaron but luckily for him he's saved by
mikasa
the warhammer titan goes on to create
many interesting weapons including a
sword
and a giant cattle nine tails whip that
can straight up slice through buildings
aaron is very clever during this battle
and
realizes that the body of the warhammer
titan materialized from the feet up and
he uses this knowledge to find the tiber
sister
in her crystal underground here a
potential weakness of the warhammer
titan is revealed aaron's titan breaks
the cord connecting the crystal to the
warhammer titan and then the warhammer
titan stops working the crystal must be
connected to the titan for it to work
the tiber sister then creates another
partial warhammer titan and
from it branch-like spikes grow and trap
aaron's titan aaron's titan still
holding the titan crystal
tries to bite through it but to no avail
like annie's crystal he finds out it's
practically unbreakable
at this point with an unbreakable
defense and the ability to just reform
the warhammer titan body again and again
the warhammer titan seems pretty
unbeatable and if things remained like
this it would have remained undefeatable
however
in time we find out that the jaw titan
can
actually cut through the titan crystal
with its claws and jaws as i mentioned
an
insane detail that made the jawtine so
much cooler in my eyes
if porco's jaw titan wasn't there they
probably never could have gotten her out
of that
crystal just like with annie ironically
by trying to help porco actually
revealed the only way for aaron to
absorb the warhammer titan was to use
porco as a nutcracker titan
and he did and thus gained the op
warhammer titan power for himself
you might wonder why the warhammer titan
didn't keep
forming warhammer titan body after
warhammer titan body to defeat aaron the
crystal was detached from the ground
which might have something to do with it
but my main guess would be that the
tiber sister
used up too many transformations and too
much energy see some titan shifters can
transform more times than others peak
can easily transform into the cart titan
four times in a row
and according to her many more times
than that its endurance is crazy
compared to the other titan shifters
especially compared to the colossal
titan who is way more limited when it
comes to number of transformations
mageth points out later that a good
strategy for the warhammer titan
is to make it use its power although its
power is immense
it is quickly exhausted so all those
spikes and cool weapons come at a price
you won't necessarily do well in a
prolonged battle
thus the titan crystal is a great backup
defense strategy
at least when the jaw titan is not
present aaron also explains
other ways the warhammer titan can be
useful to hanji usually you can trap
titan shifters by sticking them
underground where their titan
transformations are useless
not so with the warhammer titan power
aaron tells hanji and i quote the
warhammer titan controls
titan hardening to create weapons or
anything it needs from underground
it was an annoying enemy in other words
you can't imprison me
no matter how tough and deep underground
this cell
is i can leave here whenever i want end
quote the annoying enemy part again goes
to show how strong this titan power
is and if it weren't for mikasa aaron
would not have won that battle
especially because he didn't fully
understand the warhammer titans powers
in the beginning
and furthermore the usual weakness of
titan shifter's i.e being placed
underground
doesn't affect him aaron proves that he
wasn't bluffing when they later
find out that he used the warhammer
titan power to create an escape route
and then sealed the hole to prevent
anyone from following him
now let's cover aaron's extensive use of
the power when marlene forces finally
attack paradise island
we gotta keep in mind that aaron is now
using it in combination with his attack
titan so he can't make claims that a
warhammer
titan alone could do as well as aaron
does in this battle because he has
multiple titan powers
although the founding titan power hasn't
been unlocked yet nevertheless he
definitely relies heavily on the
warhammer titans powers by creating
spike after spike
throughout the battle he creates spikes
from his back
and when he is being overpowered by
reiner and porco's titans
he creates spikes from the ground to
impale them both this is very impressive
but then peaks card titan who's carrying
anti-titan artillery on her back
launches an anti-titan shot at aaron and
this gives reiner and porco
more time to escape this three-on-one
situation would be hard if not
impossible for anyone else but with the
consistent spikes aaron succeeds in
holding
reiner and peek back for the most part
he manages to stay alive until the beast
titan shows up
and there is no way he would have been
able to do that without the warhammer
titan power here
and now fast forward with amir fritz
serving him aaron is able to summon as
many warhammer titans of the past as he
wants
he has the tiber sister one form a
trident and stabbed peak
and other versions form bows and arrows
or crossbows
or throwing spears so that they can
launch projectiles at falco's flying
titan or other enemies
it's possible that this ability to
summon more titan shifters of the past
relies on the warhammer time power as
well as the founding titan power
because the past titan shifters appear
similarly to how the tiber sisters
warhammer titan
appeared in the past obviously the
founding titan just unlocks a completely
different level of power though
either way the warhammer titan power is
very impressive
obviously no titan power can compare to
the power of the founding titan which
aaron has used to command
countless colossal titans resurrect
titan shifters of the past to do his
bidding
and much more still if we ignore the
founding titan and the warhammer
titan-specific weakness
meaning to draw titan the warhammer
titan could fare very well against the
others
without the founding titan there to take
control of it and the jaw tightened
there to break through the
indestructible crystal
nobody else could give the user a
definitive defeat and as i mentioned the
titan crystal power
may be specific to the warhammer titan
and annie might have got it when marlei
forced her to choke down parts of the
warhammer in the past because one of the
female titans abilities as i explained
is to take on characteristics of the
titan whose parts she consumed
this is just a theory but it would make
the warhammer titan even more op
if the titan crystal was specific to it
instead of all the titans having the
potential to learn it but even if all
the other titan shifters did have
potential to learn how to form these
crystals around their bodies the
warhammer titan seems to be the only one
that can actually summon a titan and
fight
while remaining in this safe crystal and
when it's in this crystal the colossal
tines explosion the armor tightens
hardened punches
the beast titans throws and the attack
of the other titan shifters like the
attack female and cart would have no
effect
while the others would have to avoid the
deadly spikes and weapons of the
warhammer which include long range
weapons
even against the jaw titan it's possibly
could get the user
with an arrow or that it could trap them
with the spikes jutting out of the
ground
before the jaw tanker get close but it
probably still would be a close fight
against the jaws in a one-on-one battle
because of the jawtine swiftness
and its super effective claws and jaws
and with the colossal titan it wouldn't
be easy but the best strategy would
probably be to wait until it exhausts
itself unless you can somehow get off
the perfect arrow that hits its name and
kills the user but this would be easier
said than done because the colossal
titan could probably use its steam
emission ability
to send the arrow off track and there
you have it the warhammer titan and how
it may match up against some of the
other titans it has many strengths like
being able to make all sorts of weapons
being able to make all sorts of spikes
that could straight up lift other titans
into the air or simply trap them
being able to operate remotely from a
place of safety in a near indestructible
crystal
and being able to escape from
underground prisons its weaknesses
include the fact that its power can be
quickly exhausted when it overuses its
advanced hardening powers
and if it's being operated remotely the
titan body can be stopped by destroying
the cable that connects it to its user
considering both its strengths and
weaknesses it remains one of my favorite
titan powers
let me know which ones are your favorite
in the comments and why thanks for
watching if you did enjoy this video and
want to keep them coming then the best
thing you could do is
warhammer smash that like button
obliterate it like exodia
and let me know what titan you would
like to see
covered next in the series and fyi i
already covered how strong zeke's beast
titan is in a recent video
that i'll link in the description if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell and
select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos and while you wait for the
next new video to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
time rank for weak is the strongest
and much much more link to that is in
the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself and the most donated
champion of the world
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect pate heparithian
emperor otaku spidey life tinel fake
buddhist and tungsten tarkis and
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazowski joel stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fond ruthu and deora
alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water the
red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz anthony
schreiber
hi jinx and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you